à force d'ailleurs de parler comme ça du
passé est ce que parfois vous n'êtes pas
un petit peu juste et moins nostalgique
de ce passé et les années s'écoulent en
essais gré non beaucoup d'entre vous
d'entre eux en fête et de vos amis
partent et on n'a pas l'impression de se
retrouver un petit peu seul et de d'être
isolé en fait écouter avec j'ai eu une
conversation avec michel serrault qui a
mon âge à une semaine près on est
vraiment d'ailleurs vous êtes prochain
oui proches pas seulement dans la date
anniversaire les proches très fraternel
et on s'est dit il ya quelques mois on
s'est dit c'est terrible on a de moins
en moins de gens à qui parler non pas de
parler je suis heureux de parler
rizières mais pour se retrouver vous
savez l'amitié c'est le fait de
retrouver quelqu'un que vous n'avez pas
revu depuis six mois depuis un an depuis
deux ans et brusquement la conversation
s'enchaînent comme si vous n'étiez pas
quitter car vous avez non seulement des
souvenirs nostalgiques et pas seulement
à nostalgie c'est des façons de penser
cdd façon de rire c'est c'est l'intérêt
qu'on porte à certaines chez choses et
pas à d'autres